bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 22 avril au 29e jour du conflit
engagé par l'otan contre la serbie les
positions respectives le semble figé
nous serons en albanie avec aubry et de
l'air dans la zone frontalière nord-est
où des militants séparatistes nous checa
côtoient parfois les villageois et des
réfugiés kosovars à couquèques jerrycans
consignes et où de nouveaux groupes de
familles de réfugiés viennent d'arriver
à tetovo en macédoine où l'équipe de
france 2 avec valérie fournis ou à 6,7 à
l'installation d'un nouveau camp au
monténégro avec maryse burgot pour
rendre compte de la manifestation
organisée par les partisans de slobodan
milosevic
nous évoquerons l'interview du dirigeant
serbe diffusé par une chaîne américaine
ainsi que les démarches diplomatiques
russes avec notre correspondant à moscou
gilles rabin
enfin nous tenterons de comprendre les
conséquences du conflit dans les pays
voisins dont la bulgarie dans
l'actualité également une drôle de grève
en france à la société générale gré
plutôt encouragé par la direction
et puis du cinéma la présentation de la
sélection des films pour le festival de
cannes 99 c'est au mois de mai prochain
chaque jour le haut commissariat de
l'onu pour les réfugiés livre une
estimation du nombre d'albanais du
kosovo qui ont fui dans les pays
limitrophes au 29e jour du conflit
l'estimation globale est d'environ 600
mille personnes regardez cette carte
près de trois cent soixante mille
d'entre eux se trouvent en albanie une
équipe de france 2 avec aubry et de
l'air et batterie voix s'est rendu au
nord-est du pays dans le district de
trop payer la frontière avec la
fédération yougoslave est tout proche
il y a quelques jours des unités de
l'armée serbe y aurait fait non loin une
incursion dans ce district de troupes
loyers des membres de l'armée
séparatiste de loups checa côtoient des
villageois albanais on pourrait se
laisser prendre par la beauté sauvage
des paysages si quelques uniforme de
loups checa la veine est rappelé que
l'avenir du kosovo se décide d'ailleurs
ce monde
anil les soldats kosovars ne se cache
pas mais ne parle pas non plus c'est à
l'aube à quelques kilomètres de la
frontière dans l'une de leurs bases de
la région que l'on vous surprendre les
hommes de lucescu
ils sont en évidence sous-équipés épuisé
ressemble plutôt à une troupe en déroute
de l'armée albanaise pas de trace cette
partie de l'albanie semble déjà
appartenir à l'histoire qui s'écrit au
kosovo pourtant les incursions et
agressions de l'armée serbe ne se
comptent plus le bourg de trop payer à
six kilomètres des premières positions
yougoslave est fréquemment arrosé de
mortier ça fait un mois que ces
bombardements ont commencé
ils ont touché ma maison celle d'en face
fait brûler plusieurs voitures c'est
pour ça que trop peu ya été évacués la
ville s'est peu à peu vidée de ses
habitants sur les 1000 personnes
recensées il en resterait une
cinquantaine tous des hommes faiblement
armé installé désormais dans leur cave
ils craignent les pillards qui pullulent
aujourd'hui dans la région et les tirs
de mortiers qui répondent souvent en
vengeance appuyé aux attaques de l'otan
sur la serbie les femmes et les enfants
sont en sécurité maintenant
mais tous les hommes en état de se
battre sont restés car nous craignons
une invasion de l'infanterie serbe toute
la zone frontière semble gagné par la
frayeur et le désarroi
on croise sur les chemins défoncés de
misérables paysans que cette guerre qui
se dit encore étrangères conduit à
l'exil temporaire les serbes
ils sont juste au dessus de nous ils
peuvent nous bombarder quand ils veulent
et nous on n'a qu'un fusil on cessera
pas faire s'ils veulent aussi prendre
notre pays on saura le défendre le soir
venu on distingue sur la crête les
sentinelles serbe
les habitants des hameaux les plus
isolés se rassemblent dans des bunkers
un demi siècle de dictatures paranoïaque
en a fait pousser plus de 700 milles en
albanie ici les regardais souvent la
peur et l'incompréhension
on perçoit aussi
parfois plus fort encore un sentiment
mêlé de colère et de haine
nous on n'a nulle part où aller alors on
se battra jusqu'au bout pour garder
notre terre où on peut se battre avec
n'importe quoi ils resteront intérêts
des heures peut être la nuit entière
callen leur vie désormais sur le va et
vient des avions de l'otan
ouvrier de l'air vous est maintenant de
retour à tirana la capitale albanaise et
donc traversé tout le nord du pays
quelles sont les impressions est-ce que
vous avez l'impression qu'ils aient une
grande désorganisation de ce pays
actuellement
je crois que le meilleur exemple pour
vous décrire l'état dans lequel et
l'albanie aujourd'hui c'est de vous dire
que pour franchir les 250 kilomètres qui
séparent tirana de trop foyer il nous a
fallu près de dix heures les routes sont
défoncées les villes en abandon complet
et les usines en ruines
on a l'impression d'une vaste casse
alors dans le nord on a plutôt
l'impression d'un no man's land il n'y a
pas de police il n'y a pas d'armé c'est
la mafia qui s'en emparer du terrain l
attaque tout ce qui passe sur la route
les convois de réfugiés mais aussi les
étrangers de passage ong journalistes
alors il ya aussi des témoignages que
vous avez esquissé dans dans votre
reportage notamment ceux de l'ue checa
mais quel est l'état de lucia est ce que
sont des combattants très structuré très
organisé c'est difficile à dire parce
que vous l'avez vu le tchèque n est pas
très coopérative
mais le hasard a voulu que sur la route
du retour nous voyagions avec un ex
sous-officier britannique il forçait
l'uniforme de l'ugtg et car il s'est
porté volontaire il y a trois semaines à
passer son temps dans le nord de
l'albanie et notamment dans là dans le
camp que j'ai pu voir dans le reportage
il dit avoir eu plusieurs dizaine de
recrues sous ses ordres venus de
macédoine il a également cité la
belgique et l'allemagne
alors son témoignage est à vérifier mais
est alarmant ce qu'il dit c'est que ces
sommes sont sous-équipées imaginez qu'il
leur a appris le maniement d'armes
légères ont cédant de bâton il a parlé
d'armement
our citant de vieux canons d'aidé dont
probable de l'armée albanaise il serait
également sous-alimentées l'ordinaire
serait du pain de la soupe de haricots
et puis surtout et c'est peut-être le
plus grave il a trouvé ces volontaires
kosovars extrêmement démotivés et
particulièrement inapte à se battre ils
ne connaissent pas le terrain et ne sont
sûrement pas prêt à affronter les
positions serbes
merci oui un peu plus au sud sur ce même
territoire albanais à cuq est de nouveau
plusieurs centaines de villageois du
kosovo ont franchi la frontière ils ont
raconté avoir marché plusieurs jours
plusieurs nuits l'exode continue donc
reportage anne consigny dj cela ils sont
venus à pied pour la plupart de
mitrovica part qu' il y une dizaine de
jours
ils sont huit cent quarante et attendait
cet après midi des camions de transport
sur la prairie attenante au poste
frontière
au loin les militaires serbes font le
guet décontractée ces réfugiés constitue
le plus grand groupe qu'ils soient
passés depuis dimanche
il apporte peut-être avait que
l'explication de cette interruption
l'exode il y a quatre jours à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres et servent
les ont arrêtés en leur disant qu'un bus
allait les emmener au bout d'un moment
une voiture de police est arrivée ils
nous ont dit fait demi tour
parce que les vôtres ne veulent plus de
vous
mais en nous de notre côté église il n'y
a pas de problème les oeufs les albanais
ils ne veulent pas tout on allait de
byakko va à prizren et là on nous a fait
faire 2000 tony n'a ensuite on est resté
quatre jours dans le village de tout
était détruit sur nos côtes dans les
maisons en ruines
il y avait des positions de l'armée
yougoslave à l'aller les animaux et
recel dans les champs
leur témoignage ne permet pas de
confirmer l'existence de la colonne
immense brutalement disparu dont il a
été question ces derniers jours
ces hommes et ces femmes en route
raconte seulement que les termes semble
gérer le flux des réfugiés à leurs
frontières mais selon des critères qui
nous échappe pour reprendre maintenant
la carte de l'état des lieux de cette
région où se trouvent les réfugiés après
l'albanie vous le voyez la macédoine où
l'onu estime à plus de 132 mille le
nombre de réfugiés
la macédoine connaît d'extrêmes
difficultés à la frontière avec le
kosovo au village de malina c'est dans
la montagne les organisations
humanitaires ont eu beaucoup de mal à
obtenir des autorisations pour secourir
les personnes bloquées dans ce village
commentaires nathalie moison les portes
de l'exil de nouveau ouverte après trois
jours de quasi fermeture la frontière
macédonienne a vu passer quelques
milliers de réfugiés aujourd'hui
difficile pour autant de savoir s'il
s'agit là d'un nouvel exode
ils continuent d'affluer et pourtant en
macédoine
la situation des réfugiés n'en finit pas
de se détériorer son petit peu bien
essayé de la réconforter
rien n'y fait ces réfugiés puis les
villages de la montagne au nord où ils
viennent de vivre plusieurs jours dans
le froid et sans vivre oui que ça d'être
vives
on a décidé de partir comme des chats
parce que les conditions étaient
vraiment très mauvaise on n'avait pas de
nourriture de médicaments
il y avait beaucoup d'enfants et des
femmes des réfugiés bloqués à la
frontière loin de toute aide humanitaire
ce camion du programme alimentaire
mondial n'ira pas jusqu'au village de
malines à la police macédonienne
l'empêchera de passer officiellement
pour des raisons de sécurité et lorsque
la responsable humanitaire locale
explique la situation aux journalistes
présents
un militaire m'a c20 l'interview en elle
baigne aussi particulièrement dans la
région frontalière de mukesh la
situation est explosive alors le hcr a
organisé ses premières rotations
d'hélicoptère vers le sud du pays
notre priorité cette vidéo la région
coup qu'est ce qui n'est pas approprié
pour recevoir autant de réfugiés chez
eux mais faute de coordination entre
l'otan et le hcr et parce que nombre de
réfugiés n'ont pas envie de quitter la
région frontalière
seuls quelques-uns ont pu être évacués
vers le sud aujourd'hui
alors sous la pression des organisations
internationales humanitaires les
autorités de la macédoine laisse
maintenant construire deux nouveaux
camps il s'agit d'accueillir plusieurs
milliers de réfugiés des travaux ont
commencé depuis le début de cette
semaine près de tetovo c'est une ville
où réside essentiellement des
macédoniens d'origine albanaise
reportage valérie fonio et frédéric
basket
smaili ceni et ce groupe d'ouvriers
macédonien comme mimi serbe
il a beau être un élu de la commune il
est surtout albanais il n'en saura pas
plus sur ce nouveau quand on chantiers
lancés par le gouvernement macédonien
un conte qui ne sera pas opérationnel
avant dix jours selon ces norvégiens
chargée d'implanter le système d'eau
courante prépare à organiser ce camp
pour qu'il soit durable car nous ne
savons pas combien de temps les réfugiés
vont rester il y a trois semaines les
autorités macédoniennes avait commencé
le chantier puis l'ont arrêté
aujourd'hui relancé c'est un espoir pour
cette commune à 97% albanaise le village
a déjà accueilli plus de 3600 réfugiés
qu'ils ont dû loger et nourrir sans
recevoir pour autant dead de notre
gouvernement
haskell si malheureusement le
gouvernement macédonien ne nous informe
pas en ce qui concerne les camps ce sont
les organisations humanitaires et les
gouvernements de l'alliance qui le font
thierry à la création du camp les
rassure car les organisations
humanitaires seront aussi là pour les
aider eux que le gouvernement macédonien
n'aime guère notamment pour des raisons
politiques on marie et au kosovo c'est
un militant de noche qu'à notre armée de
libération n'a pas assez d'armes
il faut que les forces terrestres
allemande américaine enfin que toutes
les troupes de l'otan interviennent
c'est à dire que ce qu'on se construit
parce que je crois qu'il y aura encore
des réfugiés
jusqu'à ce que murray celui qu ils
vivent après sa mort
ça va s'arranger mais le gibus vivant il
n'y a pas d'arrangement dents
les balkans en attendant la création du
camp l'entr'aide entre albanais se
poursuit ici
vaille que vaille entre frères de sang
au partage on rompt le petit noir mais
parfois nous aurons quelque chose à
manger et aussi pour manger quitte à
donner le dernier morceau de pain
destinés à nos enfants c'est qu'ils sont
les plus pauvres des pauvres ici en
macédoine
la plupart sans travail des nuits de
tous car albanais au monténégro la
police fidèle au président du canot
beach a repris le contrôle d'un poste
frontière avec la croatie malgré les
pressions de l'armée serbe
cependant la manifestation qui se tenait
en fin d'après-midi à podgorica la
capitale en faveur de ce club à dan
milosevic montrait bien la fragilité du
pouvoir indépendant monténégrins
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux maryse
burgot et gilles jacquier il s'appelle
mon marboula tôt fitch
il dirige le parti socialiste populaire
monténégrins
c'est lui qui a organisé cette
manifestation pro milosevic ce soir à
pau dont il tint la capitale de la
république
l'hymne national de l'ex yougoslavie
raisonne sur la place principale
tous ici sont contre les frappes de
l'otan
ils sont venus avec des cibles imprimés
sur des affiches ils disent leurs débuts
de voir l'alliance atlantique frappé la
serbie et le monténégro
ces frappes sont injustes il n'attaque
un taux de l'innocent
une manifestation surveillé par les
militaires fédéraux fidèles à slobodan
milosevic
mais aussi par la police monténégrine
qui soutient le président réformateur
milo djukanovic
pas d'incident à l'heure où nous parlons
la foule se contentant pour l'instant de
fustiger le président pro occidental
actuellement au pouvoir
c'est que nous au monténégro on soutient
la serbie mais voulons préserver
l'intégrité du territoire young stars et
nous accusons de pouvoir débutants de
l'actuelle présidente jokanovic
l'organisateur de la manifestation
moumar bulatovic est considéré comme le
relais de slobodan milosevic au
monténégro battu ici aux dernières
élections présidentielles c'est un match
sérieux désir de revanche
les gens qui ne le sont pas seulement
contre les boîtes le temps ils sont
dotés pour que la république du
monténégro est à l'intérieur de la
fédération autonome
de l'actuel gouvernement de cette joute
anneaux rixe selon belgrade 517 civils
auraient été tués depuis le début des
bombardements de l'otan en yougoslavie
le ministre serbe qui a donné ces
chiffres ajoute 4000 civils blessés mais
refuse tout bilan concernant l'armée
yougoslave la nuit dernière l'otan a
frappé à pristina belgrade et nouveau
symbole fort pour le temps c'est la
résidence de ce que boonen milosevic
dans le centre de la capitale serbe qui
a été détruite commentaires françois
corner on l'appelait le palais blanc
construite dans les années 30 sur les
hauteurs de la capitale yougoslave
cette villa cossue où le maréchal tito
avait habité jusqu'à sa mort en 1980
était la principale résidence de
slobodan milosevic à belgrade le
président yougoslave et sa famille ne se
trouvait pas dans les lieux au moment du
bombardement
vers 4 heures ce matin depuis le début
des frappes de l'otan
le couple présidentiel ne dort que dans
des bunkers ils en changent chaque soir
et ne passe jamais deux nuits au même
endroit belgrade accuse bien sûr
aujourd'hui le temps de tentatives
d'assassinât contre le président
yougoslave la résidence de milosevic a
déclaré aujourd'hui à washington le
directeur du renseignement militaire
américain disposait de capacités de
commandement et de contrôle
et c'est la raison pour laquelle elle a
été visée immédiatement après le porte
parole du pentagone confirmait que
l'objectif de l'otan était je cite de
décapiter le régime sans plus et
milosevic
nous visons les infrastructures
militaires et les troupes qui
soutiennent les instruments de la
répression et au kosovo
cet après midi à belgrade les syndicats
ont appelé à une grande manifestation de
soutien au président milosevic et à la
presse yougoslave qui seul d'après ces
manifestants et les leaders syndicaux
vie la vérité la presse occidentale ce
site ne raconte que des mensonges sur le
kosovo
à l'heure de cette manifestation l'otan
frappe est une nouvelle fois ce dernier
pont de novi sad enjambant le danube en
voïvodine déjà touchée il y a trente six
heures par un bombardement mais qu'il
n'avait pas été totalement détruit un
mois de frappes aériennes et de
destruction un mois d'exode pour des
centaines de milliers d'albanais du
kosovo mais slobodan milosevic ne paraît
pas du tout affecté il a accordé une
interview à la chaîne américaine cbs
interview réalisée par une filiale de
cette chaîne dont le siège est à houston
au texas
alors nous avons voulu ce soir décrypter
les conditions de cet entretien qui fait
partie de la propagande serbe
proba qu'amd réussi disait récemment
madame albright secrétaire d'état des
états unis
explications sur cette interview avec
hervé brusini je crois que nous avons
utilisé tout notre temps au moins une
heure
ouanna président milosevic je vous
remercie au nom du peuple américain
d'avoir partager vos vues avec nous et
nous espérons qu'on pourra régler ce
problème dans l'art p et très vite
mais pourquoi slobodan milosevic et ils
accepter un tel entretien à une
télévision américaine
et pourquoi l'interviewer ici de dos qui
représente la 11e chaîne de houston au
texas at il obtenu cette rencontre en
fait
ronald à jet n'est pas journaliste mais
professeur à l'université de st thomas
houston c'est un expert militaire qui
possède des contacts étroits avec une
association pro serbe de l'état du
montana
elle s'intitule paix sans violence dans
les balkans elle a proposé deux choses
au professeur voir les pilotes
américains prisonniers à belgrade
et cet entretien avec le leader
yougoslave la chaîne texane n'aura pas
d'image des pilotes mais bel et bien
l'interview
c'est une filiale du réseau cbs comme il
en existe près de 300 états unis
on y parle beaucoup de faits divers
locaux eu de politique étrangère
d'ailleurs c'est une télé serbe qui a
tourné les 60 minutes dans le palais
présidentiel de belgrade
beaucoup de visiteurs et leur milieu des
visiteurs de haut rang ont toujours dit
que nous étions un exemple pour les bons
traitements des minorités nationales
à aucun moment le professeur
l'interrompt la propagande du leader
serbe qui d'ailleurs donnera lui même la
clé de cet entretien pour lui en ce
moment il y a deux guerres l'une est
militaire et l'autre guerre est une
guerre des médias
et c'est ainsi qu'en pleine guerre via
une petite chaîne du texas slobodan
milosevic et réussit son coup franc
parler aux américains et au monde comme
s'il le faisait avec sa propre télé
l'envoyé spécial de boris eltsine
monsieur victor tchernomirdine n'était
aujourd'hui à belgrade pour un entretien
et un dîner médiation ex-lausanne
milosevic il a rappelé le plan de paix
proposé par moscou aux autorités serbes
maison ne connaît pas les réponses de
ces dites autorités
explication gilles rabin et franck
brisset quand il quitte moscou tôt ce
matin victor tchernomirdine ne sait que
deux choses les entretiens qu'il va
avoir avec milosevic ne vont pas être
faciles et en termes diplomatiques ces
panoplies misme dans le poker menteur
qui se joue autour des balkans la russie
n'a pas les bonnes cartes
elle manque d'atouts maîtres dans son
jeu si l'ancien premier ministre russe
est encore accueilli comme un allié
belgrade le président yougoslave sait
qu'il ne lui apporte pas de bonnes
nouvelles
non seulement toute aide militaire est
désormais catégoriquement exclu mais de
surcroît le soutien diplomatique de la
russie à la yougoslavie n'est plus
inconditionnels la position de moscou a
changé le kremlin
marc ses distances avec milosevic et son
régime mardi dernier alexei le
patriarche orthodoxe de russie avait
oser oser parler devant un milosevic
muet et devant les caméras yougoslave
des souffrances des kosovars déplacées
ou réfugiées dans une allusion directe à
la campagne d'épuration ethnique dont
les citoyens serbes ne savent toujours
rien un avertissement donné en parfait
accord avec le kremlin et répété devant
10000 personnes à l'issue d'une messe
des morts concélébrée avec le patriarche
serbe pavle plus grave pour belgrade
tous les plans de sortie de guerre
qu'ils
multiplient reprennent les conditions
posées par l'otan le dernier en date
celui du président de géorgie edouard
chevardnadzé ici mardi dernier avec
tchernomirdine prévoit un cessez le feu
qui permettrait un arrêt des
bombardements et en retrait simultané
des forces serbes au kosovo l'ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères de
gorbatchev joie lourd en diplomatie est
invité au sommet de l'otan à washington
qu'il aura donc l'occasion de soumettre
son plan aux américains quant au plan
russe exposé par igor ivanov
le ministre des affaires étrangères de
russie en voyage officiel au proche
orient
ils butent toujours sur la composition
d'une future forces de sécurité
internationale au kosovo et sur
l'acceptation de cette présence
militaire parmi les civils
voilà pourquoi malgré plus de six heures
d'entretiens aujourd'hui à belgrade
carnot mire dit lui-même disait qu'il ne
fallait pas attendre de résultats
décisifs immédiat le sable alors gilles
rabin après le premier déplacement de
messieurs primakov un deuxième
déplacement celui de monsieur thierno
myrdhin mais quels sont les arguments
quelles sont les chances qu'ils peuvent
faire changer la donne
écoutez la médiation monsieur primakov
claude était intervenue au sixième jour
des bombardements s'étaient
manifestement trop tôt et d'ailleurs à
l'époque mais ma copine ne le cachait
pas s'il avait fait le voyage de
belgrade s'était d'abord pour remettre
la russie dans le jeu car de verdi lui
vient après un mois de bombardements et
il est clair que ces arguments ont été
écoutées avec plus d'attention et moins
d'intransigeance parmi les civils quant
à ces arguments justement il tourne
autour du recentrage de la position
russe position russe qui se rapproche
chaque jour un peu plus des positions
des pays européens de l'otan recentrage
claude qui amène la russie aujourd'hui à
mettre sur le même plan l'arrêt des
bombardements de l'otan et l'arrêt des
violences et au kosovo a accepté le
principe d'une force internationale de
sécurité et enfin à faire du retour des
réfugiés une priorité aussi impérative
que le sauvetage de la souveraineté de
la serbie
merci gilles à washington les dirigeants
des 19 pays alliés membres de l'otan
devaient célébrer les 50 ans de cette
organisation mais le conflit engagé au
kosovo a tout changé
les entretiens commenceront réellement
demain laurent boucher l'ordre du jour
est donc largement modifier le volume
enclos je vous l'avais dit à l'origine
c'était
ce sommet devait parler des 50 ans de
l'alliance atlantique et de sa victoire
sur la guerre froide
et puis préparer aussi de l'entrée de
l'otan dans le 21e siècle évidemment la
sphère du kosovo a tout changé
déjà demain matin le sommet va commencer
par une sorte de deux conseils de guerre
entre les 19 chefs d'état des 19 pays de
l'alliance
et puis peut-être plus important
dimanche matin à ses dix-neuf chefs
d'état vont se joindre les responsables
des pays qui ont une frontière commune
avec la yougoslavie
c'est à dire la bulgarie la roumanie la
croatie la macédoine la bosnie et
l'albanie
la hongrie elle faisant déjà partie de
l'otan avec ses 130 km de frontière
commune avec la serbie alors il ya une
grande interrogation vont ils parler
d'une opération thérèse vont-ils la
définir
ils vont ils donner une date oui claude
évidemment sous la pression des médias
et de l'opinion publique ils vont parler
de cette intervention terrestre
mais c'est une hypothèse qui va être
évoquée comme autre chose qu'il faut
savoir d'abord avant toute chose c'est
que les plans de cette intervention
thérèse qui ont été établis il ya
maintenant six mois sont quotidiennement
mises à jour ce n'est pas beaucoup de
travail que de les mettre à jour
et puis il faut savoir aussi que même si
les américains et les anglais sont
plutôt pour cette intervention il n'y a
pas de consensus au sein de l'alliance
les allemands et les français par
exemple son sol y sont assez opposées
opposée ce qui veut dire qu'il n'y aura
pas de décision formelle sur cette
intervention
de toute façon on va aussi parler
d'autre chose on va parler de
l'intensification des frappes on va
parler de l'entrée en lice des
hélicoptères apache pour aller détruire
un peu plus l'armée serbe au kosovo
on va parler aussi de l'embargo
pétrolier sur la serbie
le problème pour les membres de
l'alliance c'est de rester unis de
rester cohérents avec ce qu'ils ont
entrepris il ya maintenant quatre
semaines
merci laurent tout autour du kosovo et
de la serbie les pays frontaliers
subissent les conséquences du conflit
parfois ces pays demandent à entrer dans
l'otan parfois est le plus souvent il
sollicite des aides financières
craignant d'être déstabilisé
économiquement déjà les pays de l'otan
envisage une sorte de nouveau plan
marshall tel qu'il fut mis en place au
lendemain de la deuxième guerre mondiale
sur cette zone des balkans
éprouvé par le conflit en cours
commentaire gérard
premiers touchés l'albanie le pays le
plus pauvre d'europe l'agriculture est
encore importante et les entreprises
sont archaïques 30 % de chômeurs
l'afflux de réfugiés augmente et la
population de 10 % en un mois
tout cela alors que la mafia gangrène
l'économie locale le pays reste un pays
sous perfusion en grande difficulté
politique
et n'oublions pas non plus que 1 million
d'armes et évoluent des volets début 97
dans les casernes albanaise et ses
millions d'armes est encore dans la
nature
la macédoine elle a perdu son principal
partenaire commercial
la yougoslave et les investisseurs
étrangers se sont retirés le taux de
chômage frise les 40 %
les européens sont prêts à accorder un
moratoire sur sa dette
mais ça ne suffira pas à l'ouest la
bosnie tout juste sorti de la guerre 50
% de chômeurs en un mois elle a perdu un
cinquième de ses activités économiques
la croatie s'en sort mieux elle est plus
riche mais les touristes ne se
bousculent plus c'est aussi le cas de la
hongrie
enfin alès la roumanie était déjà en
pleine récession avant la guerre depuis
elle faire 300 millions de francs par
semaine une partie de son commerce
passer par la yougoslavie la bulgarie
encore plus enclavées avait adopté un
plan de privatisations et espérer des
investissements de l'ordre de 6
milliards de francs elle n'espère plus
rien et se retrouve avec une inflation
record de 1000% alors parmi ces pays des
balkans nous avons donc choisi ce soir
de nous intéresser plus particulièrement
à la bulgarie depuis deux ans l'économie
était à peu près stabilisée mais niveau
de vie des bulgares restent très bas les
difficultés de circulation des
marchandises conséquences du conflit au
kosovo peuvent être très dommageable
pour la bulgarie reportage jean bernard
schmidt et dominique bonnet
un mois que la barge est à quai
le bateau est comme abandonnés le long
du danube chaque jour le capitaine et le
directeur de la compagnie viennent
l'inspecter pour la forme avant le
conflit ce bac transporter jusqu'à
trente six camions à travers l'europe
ils ont coupé les trajets à partir d'ici
et jusqu'à l'allemagne et depuis nous ne
faisons plus rien alors nous cherchons à
faire des trajets plus courts
non mais vous savez ça ne remplacera pas
il ya pourtant un trafic qui continue
mais il permet juste de franchir le
fleuve la frontière entre la bulgarie et
la roumanie et le problème c'est qu'il
ya parfois des dizaines d'heures
d'attenté depuis le début de la guerre
toutes les routes passant par la
yougoslavie sont fermés la traversée du
fleuve est le passage obligé pour les
camions jusqu'ici c'était tranquille la
plupart des poids lourds préfet par la
ferme
maintenant on se retrouve tous ici et le
trafic est très chargé avant il passé
environ une trentaine de poids lourds
bulgares et étrangers
maintenant il en passe quatre fois plus
avec des bus et des voitures
tous ces blocages commence à peser lourd
600 millions de francs a déjà estimé le
gouvernement bulgare et l'activité de
toutes les entreprises est menacée
le complexe métallurgique de pire d'or
au centre du pays depuis deux ans son
directeur philippe rambaud s'efforce de
le remettre à flot tous les convois de
cuivre qu'ils destinent à la belgique
sont aujourd'hui détourné plus
préoccupant le propriétaire du site
l'union minière envisage un
investissement sur place de plus d'un
milliard de francs et désormais ils
doutent
nous soupçonnons que les banques vont
devenir un peu plus nerveux
si la crise continue et yves ont demandé
des garanties supplémentaires où ils
vont demander des taux plus élevés les
investisseurs étrangers ne tienne pas
seulement compte de la politique il se
laisse influencer par leur perception
générale de la région et là nous pouvons
rien faire pour sortir de cette crise
cette semaine le gouvernement bulgare a
décidé de créer une commission chargée
d'évaluer le coût de la guerre une
manière de dire aux occidentaux que le
pays n'entend pas subir les conséquences
du conflit
il a en partie été entendu puisque les
pays industrialisés ont d'ores et déjà
décidé d'octroyer une aide
supplémentaire d'un milliard et demi de
francs à la bulgarie en france selon le
ministre bernard kouchner le nombre de
réfugiés albanais du kosovo qui seront
accueillis pourrait se situer entre 5 et
10 mille ce soir à roissy 300 personnes
un peu plus de 300 personnes venues de
tirana sont arrivées elles pourraient
rejoindre dans les prochains jours des
familles d'accueil
reportage sophie mais l olivier robert
pour ce bout de chou et sa grand mère
c'est la fin d'un voyage le début d'une
autre vie qu'ils n'ont pas choisies 326
réfugiés sont arrivés il y à peine une
heure sur le sol français en provenance
des corps de macédoine et sont encore
sous le choc
ça va après 25 ans tout abandonner comme
ça en dit long c'est pas possible toute
une vie
c'est pas facile croyez moi
mon mari et mes deux enfants dans une
valise
les camions étaient regroupées seront
acheminés dans la soirée vers l'un des
neuf centres d'hébergement dont gaillon
et vernon dans l'eure
des transats comme celui ci la france en
a tant d'autres dès la semaine prochaine
aucun quota n'a été fixée mais on dit
pouvoir accueillir quelques dignes le
plus rapidement possible ces personnes
seront prises en charge sur le plan
médical psychologique etc
nous nous déplaçons les administrations
vont sur place pour régulariser leurs
papiers
les médecins vont sur place est à nous
encore une fois de faire preuve
d'ouverture et de changer nos habitudes
pour aller à leur rencontre pour
quelques centaines de personnes à l'abri
en france ou ailleurs des centaines de
milliers restent là-bas si proche et si
loin de la terre de leurs ancêtres
voilà pour l'activité du conflit au
kosovo mais pendant ce conflit au kosovo
les frappes anglaises et américaines en
irak continue des appareils f 15 et f 16
américains ont bombardé aujourd'hui des
sites de radar de défense anti aérienne
dans le nord irak en israël en pleine
campagne électorale le premier ministre
monsieur benjamin netanyahu a décidé de
fermer les bureaux palestinien situé
dans la maison d'orient jérusalem ces
bureaux sont en fait le quartier général
palestiniens et ils servent à des
rencontres avec des diplomates étrangers
rencontre que ne supporte pas monsieur
netanyahou dans le domaine des
télécommunications l'annnonce de la
fusion prochaine de l'allemand deutsche
telekom avec la société italienne
telecom italia signifie la formation
d'un groupe située en deuxième position
dans le monde et ce qui n'est pas
anecdotique ce sont deux sociétés en
partie public commentaires pascal
golomer l'annoncé de leurs fiançailles
en a surpris plus d'un une semaine à
peine après le début de leurs
discussions officielles voici donc les
deux patrons côte à côte pour annoncer
une fusion record
une de plus deutsche telekom pèse 230 4
milliards de francs de chiffre
d'affaires telecom italia 152 milliards
à eux deux ils emploient plus de trois
cent mille personnes
le nouveau groupe se hisserait ainsi à
la deuxième place du classement mondial
en termes de chiffre d'affaires et le
bal sommateurs allemands italiens et
européens contre un avantage à cette
fusion
si l'europe dit merci à cette nouvelle
compagnie pour son rôle de leader dans
l'industrie la plus importante 21e
siècle nous avons manqué la silicon
valley en europe
si nous ne voulons pas manquer la
telecom valley mais en fait si telecom
italia selon dans cette fusion
c'est avant tout pour échapper à
olivetti prête à débourser 400 milliards
de francs pour devenir le nouveau
propriétaire
quant à deutsche telekom qui a perdu 30%
du marché allemand
en un an ils espèrent trouver là les
moyens financiers de se développer aux
états unis et en asie stratégie
hasardeuse de nombreux spécialistes
les seul domaine dans lequel il peut y
avoir des économies
ce sont des économies de masse à
l'étranger lorsque les deux entreprises
regroupées voudront investir à
l'étranger et donc qu'il ya une espèce
d'effet de masse financier qui facilite
un peu les choses théoriquement mais
c'est a contrebalancé par les coûts de
la réorganisation par les coûts de la
restructuration et au total on n'est pas
du tout convaincu que cette alliance
soit vraiment bénéficiaires une très
mauvaise surprise en tout cas pour
michel bon le patron de france télécom
ne s'allie à deutsche telekom dans
plusieurs projets ils ont même une
participation croisée de leur carte
vitale 2 2% mobilisme une seule réaction
ce soir côté français sous forme de
communiqué cette fusion est une
violation explicite des accords entre
les deux groupes
tout est donc remise en cause encore
faut-il que cette fusion se fasse car
outre les actionnaires
les deux groupes devront également
convaincre car elles vendent myrte le
commissaire européen chargé de la
concurrence qui a déjà prévenu que
l'opération ne passera pas comme une
lettre à la poste
même si le faire-part est envoyée le
mariage n'est donc pas encore acquis la
grève la société générale baptisée
opération bank morte était à l'origine
destiné par les syndicats à protester
contre les projets de fusion et l'offre
publique lancée par la bnt mais ce
mouvement du personnel a été
astucieusement récupérer entre
guillemets par la direction de la
société générale commenté agnès monteux
avec roger mathurin il est midi dans
cette agence parisienne du 15e
arrondissement on baisse déjà le rideau
ici comme dans plus de 90% des agences
société générale c'est le début de
l'après-midi banque mortes dans la rue
les premiers clients sont étonnés à
l'intérieur plus personne pour répondre
au téléphone
très rapidement le directeur de l'
agence se retrouve seul avec un employé
et une fois n'est pas coutume monsieur
le directeur applaudi à la grève
aujourd'hui est un cas tout à fait
particulier salut pour ma part c'est la
première fois en 34 ans que je fais
grève
donc c'est pratique une situation de
fait inédite ici le personnel est
d'autant plus inquiet qui se trouve en
face d'une agence de la bnp
le directeur ne veut pas en rester à une
journée de simple grève comme le
demandaient les syndicats
il rejoint un millier de manifestants
réunis sur le parvis de la défense à
deux pas du siège surprise
ici pas de syndicats et une majorité de
cadres qui affirme agir de leur propre
chef
presque plus syndicaliste que les
syndicats franck a plus de cadres que
l'embryon siège s est aussi assez normal
non non c'est une rude journée syndicale
les syndicats sont organisées cette
chose je pense que toute personne qui
travailleraient société générale qui a
envie de manifester mais il fait celles
eu un mot d'ordre clair que syndicats
qui étaient contre la bnp
les contrats la bnp alors on sort
pendant ce temps les syndicats restent
dans leur bureau satisfait du succès de
l'opération dante morte mais méfiant
vis-à-vis des initiatives des cadres
j'ai fait pas mal de grève et c'est vrai
que là c'est la première fois que je
vois 100 % d' agences de fermer à leur
bon pourrait dire que c'est un succès et
c'est presque trop quoi enfin c'est ça
paraît presque pas sérieux
la direction de la société générale n'a
pourtant pas commenté cette action mais
le succès de l'opération là mais ce soir
en position de force face aux
actionnaires pour refuser la fusion avec
la bnp à air france des négociations
sont ouvertes à l'aéroport de nice côte
d'azur pour mettre fin à huit jours de
grève des personnels au sol les pluies
plusieurs mouvements sociaux affecte les
aéroports d'orly et de roissy les
négociations portent sur la réduction du
temps de travail
cinéma avec l' annonce aujourd'hui des
22 films en compétition lors du 52e
festival international de cannes qui se
tiendra du 12 au 23 mai prochain quand
nous allons faire un petit peu
d'autosatisfaction avant de parler de
tous les autres films puisqu'il y a 4
film coproduit par france 2 qui ont été
sélectionnés le barbier de séville de
mikhalkov tout sur ma mère d'almodovar
pola x de leos carax et le temps
retrouvé de raoul ruiz et j'ajoute dans
la catégorie un certain regard le film
de youssef chahine l'autre alors c'est
donc un bel hommage pour le travail de
france 2 mais il y a quand même beaucoup
d'autres films a priori passionnant pour
ce qu'anne 99,6 en détail de la
sélection avec nicole cornu d'angle les
premières émotions de ce festival seront
pour ce couple russo américain oleg
menchikov julia ormond dans une fresque
romanesque que sous la direction de
nikita mikhalkov qui tourne pour la
première fois à l'intérieur du kremlin
et revêt aussi le costume du tsar
alexandre iii pour le barbier de sibérie
c'est le film d'ouverture
comment sera ensuite la compétition avec
quatre films français
le très attendu pola x le talon de
guillaume depardieu explose dans cette
adaptation étrange de pierre où les
ambiguïtés de herman melville par les
oscars axe prix louis delluc pour le
mauvais sens en 1986 est dehors il faut
jamais le temps retrouvé de raoul ruiz
évocation baroque de la vie de proust
avec un florilège de stars l'humanité de
bruno dumont histoire de lady naïda
lieutenant de police nos vies heureuses
de jacques mayoux six personnages si
hamissi destin dans le premier film d'un
jeune réalisateur mosaïque de la société
d'aujourd'hui beaucoup des films de
cannes c'est ça c'est des petits
portraits beaucoup de choses
sentimentales beaucoup de choses sur la
famille la structure familiale
les rapports père fils mère fille frères
entre eux et c'est quelquefois qui ce
qui explose un peu bilodeau qui se
réconcilient mais beaucoup de choses
comme ça y'a moins d'ultraviolence côté
américain pas de films de grandes
compagnies mais quatre films
indépendants
le retour de jim jarmusch pour ghost of
la voie du samouraï un david lynch
nouveau avec une histoire vraie tim
robbins avec ce pradel will rock et
wonder landes de michael winterbottom
côté européen des cinéastes plus
dérangeants comme pedro almodovar avec
tout sur ma mère hommage aux grandes
actrices comme bette davis avec marisa
paredes
et des habitués comme marco bellocchio
avec l'aval ya schengen pour l'empereur
où l'assassin et manuel de oliveira
pourra cartin beaucoup de stars aussi et
cette année faye dunaway pour une
rétrospective des films d'amour pour le
lem déjà
et le film d'ouverture c'est bien le
barbier de sibérie de mikhalkov
nous arrivons à la fin de ce journal
avant de le refermer je vous rappelle
l'information concernant l'actualité du
conflit au kosovo à la veille du sommet
de l'otan à washington avec les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement des dix neuf
pays de l'alliance que les bombardements
touche la résidence de scholes mieux et
vite
la diplomatie russe tente sa chance à
belgrade mais la situation humanitaire
en macédoine et en albanie reste
toujours très critique avec l'arrivée de
nouveaux réfugiés du kosovo
dans quelques secondes la météo etc
isabelle martinez suivi du poids route
de valérie maurice à 20h55 direct paul
amar gérard leclercq et albert du roy
reçoivent charles pasqua a les deux
grandes questions le dialogue citoyen
quelles sont les causes de la violence
urbaine comment lutter contre la
délinquance
et puis le débat politique quelles sont
les leçons de la crise au kosovo
le son que client monsieur pasqua à une
heure le journal de la nuit où sera
présentée par laurence ostolaza suivi de
la 25e heure de jacques perrin demain
c'est en cinq ans dans les 4 vérités
françoise david recevra corinne pertuis
du haut commissariat aux réfugiés de
l'onu
à 13h vos trouvailles rachid arhab et à
20h béatrice schönberg à lundi bonsoir
merci
m